house go rest - Pierre - PAH and welcome
to the wolf among us in the game made by
Telltale Games which made the Walking
Dead the good one which was actually one
of my favorite games from last year so
that the expectations are pretty high
for this one I'm really excited to play
it it seems like a really cool concept
it doesn't really make sense for me to
talk about it so enough chitchat let's
just play
okay so episode 1 there's episode 2
episode 3 episode 5 oh my
I like how they love them all planned
out already alright so let's start with
episode 1 this game series adapts to the
choices you make I like that I think
telltale is a great job in feeling you
be a part of the story once upon a time
in New York City there lived the
community of fairy tale characters known
as Fabletown the fables who lived there
arrived hundreds of years ago after they
were exiled from their homelands though
the use of magic spell called glamour
they have protected their secret
community from the mundane world
sheriff Bigby wolf protects them from
each other
okay so we're we're Bigby wolf Big B I
get it five today again if you missed it
I'll record for the date hottest ever in
June 103 now and that humidity looks low
but remember the hot of the air is the
more moisture it can hold so one or
three with 31% humidity is a lot more
humid than say seven three with 31%
humidity and it is muggy out there
I never lived anywhere where there is
really humid which I'm happy about
because it seems like a [ __ ]
the wolf among us
I like to style they're obviously going
for a comic-book stylish but it looks it
looks very cool for a videogame like it
works well for it
there's I got the big bad wolf
don't smoke it's it's bad for your lungs
sometime after midnight whoa nice mr.
toad [ __ ] baby listen my ah now I don't
look human it's a problem I'll get it
I just stepped out the apartment for
just a second to see what kind of damage
this drug [ __ ] is doing ah has cut me a
break here I'll get me glamour first
thing in the morning cross my arm no
need to kick up a fuss enough excuses -
enough of your excuses toad this is
unacceptable
if you can't afford to look human you're
going to the farm it's as simple as that
you can't send me up to live with those
animals are you're told
goddammit you know what I mean go see a
witch get a glamour big big they're
bleeding me dry mate the quality of the
spell goes down but the rates keep
climbing up do you have any idea how
much it costs to have an entire family
in glamor
I don't make the rules so glamour is
like a way for them to disguise
themselves
don't make your rules sorry I can't give
you a free pass on this tone my hands
are tied Roy Roy there's too much at
stake
whatever it costs it's worth it you
don't want me catching you out of
glamour again [ __ ] you now
this is what I code you about sheriff
you're just gonna stand there do
something big B before he completely
tears up the place
oh thanks for that big big you're a real
gentleman this is the last straw big B
he asked to go what the [ __ ] is going on
so what set him off who knows why was
this time man's got a hair trigger I
avoid him as much as possible when did
he start drinking not sure he ever
stopped boy didn't know anyone else was
up there I'm really confused I hope it's
not just me what the [ __ ] nice pants
prick up shot tell me I spend more money
dad the nights are shaking again I say
you want a big bad wolf to take you away
no they get that [ __ ] back inside
you're gonna know I [ __ ] have you
here me is this hey look at me do we got
that thank you very very much
let's check the phone no welcome time
ass knock on the door first hello big
bad wolf here not that big
kind of weird haircut god damn you hey
hey you've got something on your face
[ __ ] are you talking about you stupid oh
[ __ ] kill you oh you [ __ ] alright why
do you hit it alright hey what are you
gonna [ __ ] do her I'm gonna shed your
bag out of the way before you get the
axe again it's your last warning
woody this is your last warning if you
keep on like this I won't have any
choice but to put you down put me down
you got a [ __ ] [ __ ] memory wolf that's
not how that went last time
this isn't last time my god fighting ow
gotta calm down hmm Scott is a self up
[ __ ] had enough oh [ __ ]
please [ __ ] Shaolin I'm trying but
like ugly oh damn oh snap knee cup board
damn snap and ear slap I want to take a
bath in this thing oh [ __ ]
now today sir not today or tomorrow are
the afternoon maybe this happen whose
booty supposed to be let's go
please take a nap oh [ __ ]
what's your time how are you not dead
the axe oh no no no no no no no no no of
course woody has an axe
that is bounce that's all you got you
should probably get out of here
look I'm not leaving until I get what's
mine I'm not getting [ __ ] rich all right
welcome what you are the proud you hear
me
hey it can't be nice I'm gonna make you
wait outside
Oh [ __ ] set you rogue ha ha ha ha will
you talk [ __ ] you like you [ __ ] are you
doing are you doing here these lips are
sealed
look this is just the start of a shitty
night for me I just need the money he
owes me then I can go what the hell is
going on what happened a little
misunderstanding that turned into a real
[ __ ] show don't worry you saw the best
bits there's more where I came from
girlie knock it off I was eating why was
he hitting you maybe you should ask him
that I will but I asked you first
uh-huh
he asked me if I recognized him I knew
who he was I said I didn't he started
beating on me then you showed up started
beating on him not about cover at home
I'm the watchman you [ __ ] yar save
Little Red Riding Hood from this monster
oh my god that's away broke and fruitive
bellies full up look stones and threw in
the [ __ ] River that's who the [ __ ] I
am you stupid [ __ ] hey what did I say I
said be nice or you wait out maybe I
shouldn't have done that
damn that car does not look comfortable
[ __ ] so oh she's a towed my car
Oh miss miss ha hit me a second
oh no by all means la take your time
make yourself comfortable
can I'll get you anything pillow perhaps
yes thank you told him you need to get
off the street you don't have your
glamour apologies were smashing your car
towed I'm gutted for you mate it's a
real shame that's not you is it got a
play the old man roll some things are
more important than your car
well at least you're not backing date oh
oh oh no more please no no don't put
stones in my belly
slap that no no slap oh I'm the big
battle oh no no oh now Megan it clicks
oh ah that's a good girl
that was close
oh come on thank you
thanks thanks don't mention it
I'm just getting what he owes me you all
right back there loading and Deb kartha
your eyes and the teeth you're not
really supposed to do that are you not
if I can avoid it
great broke-ass nugget
the guy's got an axe in his brain he's
not feeling it ha ha ha ha he'll be oh
oh oh you [ __ ] Barry um Blatter is
having a bad day that makes two of us I
guess it's a good thing fables are hard
to kill
suppose this damn their [ __ ] tanks
what is she finding got it that it's not
okay okay come on
of course we're the badass of course
you're gonna like her here thanks
who do you work for really
these lips are sealed sorry
how I would just tear them up and then
hey you like my ribbon sure I'm trying
to help you if you don't answer my
questions I can't help you I'm answering
them
the best that I can
I feel like we've met before isn't that
what would you said we probably have we
all sort of knew each other at one point
or another but things change I guess I
guess
uh-oh how the [ __ ] is I got a cell line
[ __ ] toe deadly yeah
you notice a car said I stop we don't
have to make any more of a thing out of
it than it already is
should we be a gentleman he hit you he
needs to pay for that I think you paid
or nothing to give sheriff I checked
besides I just swung an axe into the guy
said I'd say we're even maybe I should
be arresting you I'm not gonna be doing
this for much longer so now's your
chance
how much was it he owed you that's poor
kitty a hundred I'm guessing it'd be bad
for you to show up empty-handed is he
gonna give her the money don't do it
I'll be fine
thank God no I really wish I could help
it's okay I'll be fine
you've done enough really come on I
can't give everybody out of a bad
situation back there I'm not that Thanks
I'm still gonna need a statement I have
to go drop off what I have meet me back
at my office then it's a little late for
an office visit sheriff I'll swing by
your apartment how do you know where you
live in the smallest apartment in The
Woodlands everyone knows that really my
didn't know you should get cleaned up he
look like [ __ ] oh thanks I don't use
that term lightly some of these look
pretty bad that's harsh man that's a
little on the harsh side I tell it like
it is when I can
Hey
I need to tell you something what
what is it
you're not as bad as everyone says you
are I'll see you around wolf
surpri stow it isn't around to make a
fuss I don't like where this is going
okay good I thought something else was
gonna happen
all right so that was the intro of the
wolf among us it looks awesome so far I
hope you're both so excited I am
they like me enjoyed watching it's a sky
to come birth today I'll see you in the
next episode stay awesome bros love you
hey I kind of like tape gaming man this
is better than call of duty